ja wir sind im vierten kriegsmonate und
der krieg im osten der ukraine tobt so
bitter wie nie zuvor in den letzten
tagen haben wir tatsächlich ein hin und
her gehabt was eben zivil oder netz gibt
diese letzte oder vorletzte großstadt in
der region luhansk dort angeht diese
stadt war lange unter ukrainischer
kontrolle dann saß ortszeit wurden die
russen sie komplett erobern die ukraine
sagte ja wir sind zu 80 prozent heraus
aus der stadt die russen haben die fast
vollständig erobert doch dann geschah
etwas ja etwas seltsames etwas
vielleicht auch taktisch ist der ukraine
nämlich an hat gesagt man ist wieder
zurück man hat jetzt neue verbände
dorthin verlegt freiwilligenverbände
auch dahin verlegt von von der
fremdenlegion dieser folgen ließen mit
unter anderem amerikanischen frei
belegen europäischen freiwilligen es gab
auch wie wir gehört haben dort einen
mehrere tote von dieser region darunter
einen deutschen und der kampf um die wm
nun es geht also weiter die ukraine hat
die stadt gegen anfängliche berichte
nicht aufgegeben sondern die
straßenkämpfe gehen dort weiter die
ukraine hält das streng geheim wie das
dort ist es gibt also keine videos von
dort auch die großen veröffentlichen
aktuell keine videos was uns aber zeigt
wie schwer dort die kämpfe sind denn
immer wenn eine der beiden seiten eine
stadt erobert hat vor allem die russen
dann haben sie natürlich viel propaganda
gemacht und viele videos gezeigt die
kämpfe dort
nebenan an stärke zu und wir müssen uns
diese maschinen ja einmal angucken denn
die schweren waffen wie artillerie
waffen also die die artillerie auf der
einen seite und die selbstfahrer fetten
wie das hier auf der anderen seite
werden immer wichtiger und werden fast
zum kriegsentscheidenden medium für
beide seiten was wir hier sehen ist eine
neue aufnahme der russischen armee diese
artillerie heißt es das ist eine 152 mm
artillerie die seit 1989 etwa im dienst
der russischen armee steht oder damals
noch sowjetischen später russische armee
und die russen verfügen über mehr als
800 dieser schweren artillerie geschütze
die wir gesehen haben immer schnell
dahin fahren können wo sie gebraucht
werden sich dann ein graben wir sehen
dass hier fast versteckt sind und von
dort aus sehr genau auf ungefähr 20 bis
30 kilometer entfernung ihre art anrief
erschießen das ist aktuell die größte
gefahr für die ukraine die wir sehen das
ist das was am meisten tote verursacht
und wir müssen von präsident saleh
am tag zwischen 60 und 100 ukrainischer
soldaten sterben die meisten aufgrund
dieser geschütze die hier feiern was hat
die ukraine den angehen zu setzen sie
braucht unbedingt westliche bach wie die
ukraine selbst hat kaum selbstfaller
vierten vielleicht ein paar dutzend
russland wie gesagt über 800 davon
alleine was die ukraine bekommt dann
unter anderem diese geschützte hier das
sind britische geschütze vom typ 777 die
von der ukraine soll ich von den
vereinigten staaten aus den usa in
richtung einige sandboden einige
nächstes folgen soll 90 davon insgesamt
gesendet worden sein sind aber wohl noch
nicht alle im einsatz vielleicht 50 sind
im einsatz und wir sehen hier wie dieses
geschützfeuer tvi ukrainische soldaten
das an der front einsetzen und wir sehen
dann auch gleich im anschluss wie
verheerend wenn diese munition trifft
das sein kann in dem video geht es dann
weiter wir sehen hier wieder das habe
ich ein paar mal gezeigt einen einen
russischen panzer der hier explodiert
und wir sehen hier oben also wenn
vielleicht 400 meter höhe sehen wir da
oben den turm des panzers der weg
springt mit der kanone daran und der
dann gleich wieder zu boden geht und und
dort eben viele meter entfernt von dem
explodierten panzer einschlägt diese
waffen sind extrem wichtig für die
ukraine und das ist ihre einzige chance
auf die schlacht im osten zu gewinnen
wir haben gesagt dass diese so genannten
m 777 wurden von den usa geliefert wir
haben selbst vor allah fetten aus
norwegen beispielsweise m109 wurden
geliefert wir haben dies esa aus
frankreich davon wurden 18 stück
geliefert die auch im einsatz sind ja
nur ein land liefert weiterhin gar
nichts nämlich deutschland hier gibt es
weiterhin die ausbildung an der
panzerhaubitze 2000 die sollen noch drei
vier wochen etwa dauern und danach soll
irgendwann auch dieses geschützt in die
ukraine geliefert werden viele andere
länder waren da wesentlich schneller als
deutschland haben schon vor monaten
angefangen daran auszubilden in polen in
frankreich in litauen darin auszubilden
ukrainische soldaten und mittlerweile
kann die ukraine sich damit verteidigen
eine letzte aufnahme wollen wir uns
angucken nicht weil sie sehr strategisch
wichtig wäre aber weil sie auf jeden
fall sehr aufsehenerregend ist und zwar
sehen wir hier im extrem tiefflug
russische kampfhubschrauber wir sehen
hier das ist ein k 52 alligator der
tatsächlich wir sehen also in zwei meter
höhe etwa überfliegt das natürlich in
erster linie natürlich propaganda die
hier gemacht wird man möchte zeigen
unsere truppen haben die unterstützung
unsere truppen haben die
luftüberlegenheit
aber an dieser höhe von nur zwei
vielleicht fünf metern die der
hubschrauber fliegt sieht man eben dass
das propaganda ist rosenheim ihr nicht
die lufthoheit sie mussten russen müssen
extrem tief fliegen damit ihre
hubschrauber nicht wie bereits
hundertfach geschehen von der ukraine
abgeschlossen werden